know
motivated by what he did you know just
trying to find a spot somewhere and and
be able to help help a team and you know
in different ways
so you know
do you view your game similarly to him
and also you know how
you mentioned a little right there but
how much inspiration wasn't watching him
find that niche in the league that
you're kind of trying you know start to
find now absolutely um like i said you
know we change the games in so many
different ways especially with our
defensive i think we take our we put a
hat on our defensive you know abilities
and we run with that and that leads to
our offense and we're we're both great
play makers you know we know how to play
the right way you know or unselfish
and you know what him watching him you
know make it all the way to the finals
and helping his team you know win the
championship
you know just made me you know buckle
down and go with that much harder and uh
you know to get opportunity like he did
and to just to seize it so
you know i actually look up to him quite
a lot